Bonjour à tous,
savez-vous qu'une partie de vos
impôts sert à financer les dérives de l'écologie
radicale ? On peut citer quelques exemples,
à partir de deux-mille-vingt-huit,
la présentation d'animaux non
domestiques par les cirques seraient interdites,
les delfinarium seront interdits,
les spectacles de Volerie mobile,
c'est-à-dire les spectacles de rapaces
seront interdits.
Il va falloir indemniser
les professionnels qui vont perdre leur métier
et surtout placer les animaux.
Actuellement, des associations
écologistes radicales
milite pour la création de
sanctuaire dans lesquels seront placés les animaux,
sanctuaire qui vont être créés avec des fonds publics.
Il faut savoir que plusieurs dizaines de dossiers
sont actuellement
en attente d'agrément par l'administration,
chaque dossier pouvant
donner droit à des subvention
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à huit-cent-mille euros.
Par contre, les frais
de fonctionnement de ces
structures ne sont pas financés
et on peut supposer qu'ils deviendront des nourroirs
puisque ces animaux
qui ont besoin de manger tous les jours
ne disposeront pas de fond pour être entretenus